ừ ừ
à à
anh alo chào tất cả các bạn
à quên Đợi mình tí mình cắm tai nghe vào
nghe cho nó chuẩn đã
à à
anh alo
Chúc các bạn nghe thấy rõ rồi mà
à à
để chứng tỏ làm mic của mình thu nó rõ
phết đấy chứ kiểu mình nghe thấy tiếng
xe mạ ngoài kia được
Ừ tao lên nữa Alo bạn thấy đủ to chưa
Mình cắm tai nghe vào được nên mình nghe
được là mình nói cái như thế nào ấy đi à
Ừ khi nào chắc là mình sẽ nói vừa đủ
không to quá trình cho không bé quá nhỏ
vì
anh Alo Alo Alo ạ
Ừ thì gà à Dạo này mình cũng chẳng biết
lên on sớm để làm gì mình ngồi cũng lại
từ 7 giờ như mọi khi vậy mà
số tiền mà vào rồi cậu
giờ xóa lại có thử thử xem hôm nay mình
sẽ dậy dì Vân Vân sẽ chia sẻ gì nữa đúng
không ạ
ừ ừ
tự học lập trình nhúng nhảy qua làm web
thì thực ra là cái này tùy các bạn Các
bạn thích học lập trình gì cũng được mà
không chọn đâu ạ
anh biết bên biết lập trình rồi nhảy
sang cái mạng nào khác thì thủ bây giờ
các bạn làm web mà các bạn gửi sang làm
mát mà nó cũng được
anh nói chung bây giờ thì đằng nào cũng
sớm rồi nên mình xin phép mình chia sẻ
cho chia sẻ về cái à Ờ cách viết email
đi có bạn hỏi về cách viết email là cái
mấy cái này thì ra là không phải dân
công nghệ mình cần biết mà tất cả dân
khác cần biết mà mình trao gồ được ra nó
có ra ngay cái này Đấy cái chuyện email
này thật là bây giờ gần như mình chỉ đọc
lại những cái ghi sẵn như thế này Vì
mình thấy có nhận ở trên này nó biết rất
là đầy đủ rồi mình thấy rằng cần phải
sửa gì cả
Nhưng mà thực sự thì các bạn cậu bị chờ
các bạn kiểu chữa chuyên nghiệp các bạn
lười Tìm hiểu các bạn lời tìm ý thực ra
thì viết email hay là à
hay là thậm chí viết thư nó giống người
viết thư ở xưa thì hồi đấy Mình ở học
văn các cụ bắt luyện viết thư kinh không
như thế nào ạ
Ừ thì biết email nên kiểu dạng là có vài
cái là đúng ở trong ngày có một vài cái
không đề cập đến mình Mình sẽ thử nói
qua mấy cái chuyện này đã có tiên à Có
dòng tiêu đề này
Ê thằng đưa
nói ngay gái điểm điểm chính ở công mở
đầu chứ không phải là kéo mở bài gián
tiếp dài dòng và cuối cùng Mà em
mày đưa sang kiểu kết luận là lại em cho
anh cho em vay tiền nữa nạ nói ngay từ
lúc đầu
không dài dòng Ngày kia thế
anh không hạn chế là kiểu in hoa tất cả
Anh ngắn gọn lịch sự này không viết tắt
này nếu thưa gửi và cảm ơn này lẽ gửi
anh Kính gửi là cấp hướng sôi cuối Cảm
ơn thêm chữ ký thì càng tốt cho chuyên
nghiệp
a mắt nhỏ
nhà
mình có chỉnh gì đâu mà khiến mích nhỏ
nhỉ
Ừ chắc là mình để xa đấy Alo Alo
Ừ anh sẽ ngồi gần hơn
à à
xe tải mic thế này thì sao to hơn nào
ngon alo alo alo ô cho tao hết cỡ rồi
đấy
a tiếp theo là các bạn
anh nói chung là đại Khái ở trong này nó
còn đề cập cái mềm mà mình thấy hay ý Nó
là kiểu các bạn phải biết cách viết
giống như kiểu viết hoa sau dấu chấm
Thật sự nhiều hoang viết sai chính tả do
ngồi cậu không chân không có chấm phẩy
thôi hoặc sau chấm phẩy không biết hoa
các thứ tên riêng tên địa danh cũng phải
viết hoa là người ông kiểu
ghi Nói chung mà
a ghi nó kiểu không chuyên nghiệp với tự
nhiên là mấy ông nhắn tin hay bình luận
thì thực ra thì kệ mỗi người bé quan
điểm mỗi người như con khi gửi mail thì
muốn thể hiện mình ra chuyên nghiệp thì
và lịch sự nữa thì mình sẽ luôn biết hoa
xong rồi cậu các thứ
ạ sau đó thì ghi kiểu ví dầu dầu ế thiệu
các bạn thì dấu nó sẽ như này
ở chỗ lá mình nói
bà
cả bạn nên
abc.xyz
đấy thì các bạn sẽ thấy da kiểu cách
viết kiểu dấu câu lúc về phải có cách ra
Xô Viết như thế này so với lúc cách dai
như thế này để thử coi cái này thì mình
quên sư mất học từ đầu thôi trong đại
khác chứ không phải có kiểu cách thứ thứ
Ừ không thì mày ông gõ hẳn lên wed của
thằng Google ấy
dog.io rồi à
Ừ cái này nó sẽ tự động tạo cho ông cái
vuốt mới đấy Sau đó thì mày ông gõ hết
vào trong này nó sẽ soát hộ ông mới cái
lỗi chính tả đã cả lỗi kiểu về dầu câu
nếu mình thực sự đưa ông không nhớ mấy
cái điều đấy
ờ ờ
em có nên viết mail Việt Việt Anh lẫn
lộn công ạ Đây Ông kia cũng lại chữ Việt
các chị anh không viết hoa đúng không
Thì
sợ thì tính mình nhẹ thì ghét khi mà nói
chuyện nữa anh nửa Việt nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà giống như bạn cũng vừa để cập
này ở kia kìa Thì
mấy ông viết mail phải phụ thuộc vào
người kia là người nào không phải người
kia người nước ngoài mà kể cả đồng
nghiệp mình nhưng mà có những từ ông
không cần phải dịch ra giống nhờ cậu Br
Giả sử tôi gửi mail cho sếp hoặc là đồng
nghiệp thì ta Tôi phải sử dụng từ chuyên
ngành để người ta sẽ đọc dễ hiểu
Ừ tôi chỉ khiến khích mấy ông nữa anh
nữa việc sau khi mà Mấy ông nói chuyện
với đồng nghiệp hoặc vào trong môi
trường học tập giống như kiểu Tôi đang
dạy mấy ông này thì tôi Thỉnh thoảng tôi
sẽ nói tiếng Anh không phải để thể hiện
mà là để mà Mấy ông nhớ được từ khóa với
gì tra Google
về giá cả phải biết từ Hòa đấy không nên
dịch ra đúng không Ngoài ra thì mấy ông
không nên kiểu nữa anh về Việt được lấy
nó hơi bị ngược đời mình ý phải dùng từ
ngược đời vì kiểu thường ra chúng ta học
thêm một ngôn ngữ chúng ta thì kiểu cằm
càng khiến cái vốn từ của mình nên phong
phú Nhưng đây là mấy ông thay thế luôn
từ tiếng Việt bằng từ nước ngoài
các tiểu Thế thì nó thành dần thành
Thằng Mất gốc chứ không phải là kiểu xịn
Nó là kiểu Sính ngoại quái rồi toàn kêu
là em quên mất cái từ này dưới Đạt tự
bằng tiếng Việt thế nào ấy chỉ nhớ mỗi
từ này sẽ mà tiếng Anh thế thì nói thẳng
là mất gốc đúng không ạ
khi mặc kiểu thực sự thì
người nước ngoài nghe mày cái xong Nó
cũng không thấy tự hào Khi miếu nói nữa
nửa tiếng của ông kết hợp nửa câu của nó
đâu thật sự luôn ý Nếu mày ông đấy kỹ là
người Tây sang bên nội bên mình nói kiểu
họ sẽ cố nói hết một câu tiếng Việt hoàn
chỉnh
a cho dù kể cả kể cả họ nói ngọng nghịu
như thế nào nhưng mà họ sẽ luôn cổ nói
một câu hoàn chỉnh con mình nói chuyện
với tây vào nói chuyện với chính mình
nói chuyện với ta mình cũng phải thể
hiện lên một vài từ tiếng Anh tôi không
hiểu cái đấy lắm người ta nhìn vào là
chung rất buồn cười à
ở đây tôi tôi từng xem dây đi Evermind
về cái vụ nói nữa anh ở Việt đội khó
chịu tôi cũng thấy no trong mảng cược về
thôi đấy đương nhiên là anh ấy Bây giờ
tôi xem video gần đây của anh đấy Thì
đúng rồi anh cũng bắn được anh đều việc
hơi lạc đây một tí tiếp tục nhé Thì
Hà Nội dung có phần chào hỏi nội dung
kết thúc chữ ký hoa ạ
ô chữ ký nên có gì này ở đây đề cập rất
nhiều Nói chung là tôi thấy rất đầy đủ
thì thu phiên với ông nên đặt ở cái link
này ở đây mà cuối cùng thì ở ở dưới này
thì
nó Đề cập về cái cc và BCC Thực sự nhiều
người không biết DC acc là gì
3cc ở sẽ tạo ở bản copy nè Để mà gửi cho
người
người người kia
Ừ nhưng mà pccc nó hay hơn đấy thước à
Gần đây tôi có nói chuyện với một bạn
cũng về cái vụ ccpc này
Em ở nhà chị Giả sử là bây giờ ông gửi
mail cho gửi mail cho sếp chẳng ngại ông
dễ cc và những người nào có liên quan
rồi cái câu chuyện đấy còn ông sẽ bi cc
cho người nào mà kiểu ông muốn cười bạn
xa đấy cho họ mà mà mới cái người kia
không không biết sẽ không biết được là
ông ông gửi bạn sao để cho cho mấy cái
người PC
nó nó là na ná kiểu rạng ngời kiểu ông
ông gửi nhầm đấy Ở đây chị mấy người
biết với nhau thôi
anh nói chung mọi người nói người nào
trực tiếp thì ông gửi cho trực tiếp sau
đó dùng sẽ cc những ngày nằm có liên
quan hệ thường là như thế à
cha mẹ ông có tôi thấy ở cậu trừ khi mày
ông làm hẳn kiểu chuyên nghiệp rất là
chuyên nghiệp được kể lại chuyên gửi
mail hàng ngày mới biết DC diễn cả PC
không thường mà em không biết đâu đúng
không ạ mãi vì sao tôi mới biết rồi mà
à à
Ở đây còn nói qua về những cái kiểu mẫu
email này ạ
cô
bạn kia ta nói về vụ là trong spytech là
cái mình thương anh có ở đây đông gọi là
đây cốt của mình ở công ty rồi mở bình
thường lên
Ừ đấy thì đại đang nói cái việc là có
gợi ý cấp thiệu với thứ khi mình gõ gì
gì đó không đúng à khi cái khái niệm ở
đây nó sẽ là khái niệm kiểu các bạn sẽ
thường nói cha nó sẽ như này các bạn đầu
tiên đi
cách các bạn để cài một cái Pocket một
cái một cái gói gì đó để hỗ trợ
Ừ thì họ sẽ tra là à sẽ gõ là control CP
xong rồi bỏ install như thế này mặc định
lúc đầu các bạn sẽ phải đi show cái
Pocket control à control đấy sau mồm khi
mình restore cái Bắc Kinh này rồi thì
các bạn ấn vào thì nó sẽ kiểu sẽ hiển
thị tất cả các bác ít có chung một cõi
trên kia store của nó trên cửa hàng mà
nó Thị Kim thì các bạn sẽ yêu thương ấy
có giống như CF
mình thường anh gọi snippet đây như này
cái khái niệm snippet này là con nít nhỉ
con
Ly xuân này con vị comple jeans rồi Như
này là để gợi ý mấy cái sneak peek hoa
gạo completion nó sẽ gợi ý cho các bạn
với cậu nó sẽ đề xuất các bạn Thậm chí
các bạn sẽ gõ phím tắt thôi Tab làm các
bạn nó sẽ hiển thị đầy đủ
Ê bà thượng Trí có một vài cái hay nữa
nhưng mà giống như bạn cứ nói là dùng là
vs code giống như là mình hôm trước mình
phải cài biết code đây này Hoặc gần
những cái
pp stomoxys thì nó sẽ ngon hơn
à đấy thì tiện mình sẽ nói qua các bạn
hiểu rõ về khái niệm Editor với
với ID nhé á
Ừ kệ Editor ấy nó chính là công cụ để mà
sửa văn bản soạn thảo và sửa văn bản
dùng cái nút test này thì cái thằng Sắp
xitec này Nó là một cái Editor tất cả nó
sẽ hỗ trợ các bạn về cái vụ sửa văn bản
đưa nhiều cảnh sát Vantech này các bạn
thấy nó hỗ trợ rõ là nó gõ được cả Cốt
và màu cốt các thứ đồ ngoại nó khác cái
thằng nó toát nó phát là chẳng đi suốt
là cái gì cả đúng ngon nếu mà
em thấy bởi vì tháng ngày đương nhiên nó
ngon hơn là nó bát nhỏ tương tự Thế thì
thằng này nó cũng chịu một mức tương đối
Nó vẫn chỉ để hỗ trợ gõ và sửa văn bản
thôi cùng lớn nó nó hiển thị màu để các
bạn phân biệt ngoài nó không thêm có cái
gì cả à
Uh cho nó có thể có giống như thằng ngốc
đấy thằng có thể chuyển lại gõ văn bản
thì nó cũng sẽ tìm ra cái tờ Thế còn IDE
thì sao thứ nhất là cái điểm khác biệt
đầu tiên của bọn nó là gaz rất nặng hơn
rất nhiều so với thằng Editor cậu Cái
thằng này các bạn thấy mở lên cài Mọi
thứ rất là nhanh và giữ ẩm nhẹ ngoan
chạy nó rớt nhẹ con ID thì nó là ôm rất
nhiều cấu hình cái thứ tùy chỉnh các thử
thử thải ra nó giỡn nặng tiếp theo hita
nó sẽ hỗ trợ các bạn về việc là nó sẽ
hiển thị lỗi ở một dòng nào đó để cảnh
báo cho các bạn để ngoài bạn kiếm nói nó
ra có sẵn môi trường nó nó có môi trường
để mà chạy thử cốt cho các bạn luôn ngay
trên chính cài IDE anh nói kiểu dáng các
bạn cốt đến đâu thì màn hình này bên
cạnh các bạn sẽ hiển thị đến đấy là nó
đang hiển thị ra như thế nào cũng được
cái kiểu thế thì cái thằng Exciter nó sẽ
không đưa có điều đấy không thì nó không
còn gọi eater nữa Thế nên là IDM là sự
rất là nặng ý
Ừ nó nó vừa chạy được môi trường giả lập
để mà chạy được cốt của các bạn Sau đó
thì hiển thị ra lỗi là có vấn đề gì đó
thì cái này thì nó luôn là bài toán đánh
đổi nghĩa là bạn nào mà kiểu máy cấu
hình yếu kết hợp Bạn muốn làm gì đòn
nhanh gọn nhẹ thì các bạn vẫn nên mở
bằng y Editor Giống như mình cũng cày cả
hai đây đúng không ạ Mình cài cả
cybertech hoa vẫn chứa gần nó phát cộng
cộng đồng như các bạn có thấy ở đây đây
thì các bạn sẽ thấy loa kiểu đó là nó
lại đi tơ điều ngoan con IDE thì thì cậu
để cho các bạn làm hẳn môi trường như
kiểu làm
A gọi cũng nhân nào cũng chuyên nghiệp
đấy Kiểu bụi vỉa phải cấu hình đó Thử
thứ cấu hình khá nhiều đấy nhưng về sau
các bạn sẽ chạy ngon anh kiểm tra cốc từ
đầu đến cuối thôi các bạn ạ
cả
hai khái niệm này thì tùy các bạn các
bạn các bạn có thể dùng qua cả hai để
nói
ở
tuần này chưa chắc học xong rồi sẽ hết
đâu mình mình sẽ thử xem bởi vì hôm nay
mình dậy các bạn thì cái bài này nữa
ạ Mình chẳng hứa là cái gì à đến đến hôm
nào hôm cuối mình mới hứa được
à à
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ bắt đầu buổi
học rồi không ạ trước khi vào buổi học
này mình lại thích nói qua về cái vụ này
đó là
có bạn nói về cái vụ kiểu Tại sao anh
không hướng dẫn về WordPress
thì thử ta Câu này không phải câu lần
tiên mình được gặp ở trường mình đừng
hỏi cái này thì thứ nhất là bây giờ mình
sẽ thử nói cho các bạn cái vuốt web mà
mình đang nói ra sự có bạn nào chưa biết
Thì quét nó là như thế này đây mình sẽ
thử mở
Windows để mở bu-lông anh nữa
ở Đà Lạt
Anh Bình hình như vừa nãy mình có phải
cài đặt web về rồi Đợi mình tí
á Vừa nãy mình tải và mình giải nén rồi
nhưng mà mình lại xóa hiểu được việc
mình muốn làm lại từ đầu cho các bạn
thì các bạn này là các bạn sẽ thấy là
khi tải về và giải nén ra nó có một loạt
tất cả file này đặt sau này tác dụng gì
mình sẽ chạy thử môi trường các bạn cái
này mình đang để mổ các bạn biết rồi nhé
chứ các bạn không cần phải làm theo thì
mình mình sẽ vào trang mình vừa giải nén
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ vào được trang web
test này à
thì nó sẽ chạy nó sẽ chạy chương trình
máy của mình nhá chứ không có cái trang
này tồn tại đâu
Ừ thì ah
Ừ cái này nó sẽ ngay từ trang đầu tiên
của nó thì nó sẽ là cái trang Nếu không
dẫn cài đặt các thứ môi trường đất giữ
thử lại và nó sẽ bảo các bạn là kỳ nhập
đã tập bay sau các thứ thế này thì tất
cả các bạn phải tạo ra ta bây trước đã
mình sẽ tạm một cái Doctor Bai là web
không ạ tưởng mình sẽ tạo máy bay clip
cho tao bay Quest trở lại anh shows your
name what's your name thì nó rút này mật
khẩu trống này cái mặc định của khi mà
các bạn cài trên máy thường là mặc định
rút vẫn là mật khẩu chấm
và trên mái khi nó sẽ là lâu cổ hot đấy
submit này có thế xong rồi Ê mày Các bạn
thấy gần nhà chị nhập nhập nhập nhập đó
Kiểu như thế mà sự đời mình điên ở gái
xinh chọn lọc em ạ
email này
I install
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này nó rất giống rất
nhiều thẳng giống như là kiểu hàng à
a Quest là run la này xong rồi mà Zen tô
này cái thằng đấy là giống nhau Nó sẽ
nó làm flashform
ở đó thì các bạn thấy em nó sẽ giao ra
dưa giao diện kiểu như này các bạn hoàn
toàn thể tạo thêm Tết mới hạt New Pet
này mặc định compag rồi này son môi có
cà phê chim nè nghĩa là kiểu giao diện
tùy chỉnh như thế nào chọn giao diện các
thứ thứ các bạn muốn ăn trong cái bán
hàng này chồng có ăn gì đó Đấy xong rồi
tạo mới dùng nói chung có đầy đủ hết
trên này
Ừ nếu mà các bạn muốn thêm cái gì thì
các bạn có thể lên cái store của nó để
mở Tải thêm về lắc in về đấy
Ở đây nó sẽ là một cái khái niệm gọi là
platform
platform đề ngoại ý
đề thi đúng rồi bạn kia nói đúng nó là
làm quét bằng kéo xa thì thì không cần
phải Cốt và thực ra các bạn cũng vào
người Đọc cốt của nó vỡ mồm bạn không đi
sửa như thế nào đấy Nó kiểu vest Thì bây
giờ mình sẽ thử
Anh thường hay lấy cái ví dụ này lấy cái
ví dụ về
cô
gia sư các bạn đang
Anh đang ở trên đang ở Hà Nội đi là sự
các bạn lên Hà Nội các bạn không hề biết
đường ra bờ hồ
em đã đi đường nào về ra rằng ạ thì một
là các bạn dùng cái bản đồ giấy các bạn
sẽ mở cái bản đồ lên để mà các bạn hiểu
tự do đường đến bờ hồ tự do vị trí của
bản thân ái vân vân
hoặc là cái thứ hai đó là bạn dùng
Google Maps Mở Google Map lên để cha đưa
bóng
ưu đãi Thị Kiều Google Maps sẽ đề xuất
các bạn rất nhiều con đường và các bạn
thích nhảy sáng đều nào thì nhảy không ạ
bạn đổi hướng thì nó lại tự động đổi
hướng các bạn
thứ ba là các bạn bắt xứ xe ôm grab gì
đấy sẽ chở các bạn có thể nhanh nhất con
đường đi nhanh nhất đến cái chỗ đấy nước
ngoan
thì baby đưa các bạn câu hỏi này các bạn
vừa rồi nghe ba cách đúng không ạ Theo
các bạn thì K
có cách nào tương ứng với từng cái nào
đúng dụ là bản đồ giấy nó sẽ tương ứng
với cái nào
feroform hay là cái work
tiếp theo và dùng Google Maps thì nó sẽ
tương ứng với cái nào vào cuối cùng là
đi gọi xe gọi xe vụ xe grab là xe ôm
đúng không thì nợ sẽ tương ứng với cái
nào
ví dụ
khách sạn premium gì
z3000 này wiliam là cái gì ý
Ừ đấy thì các bạn sẽ thấy là cậu đang
phân biệt rõ các bạn về việc mấy cái đấy
đúng không tuy nhiên vì sao mình mới dậy
cụ thể tất cả những việc này
em có bạn trả lời đúng nhưng mà thiếu để
ý à
những hình ảnh về hình ảnh ví dụ mà
không thực các bạn trai thẳng cái này
thì nó sẽ ra được đúng cái bài mà mình
đã đọc và chính có cái ví dụ này thôi
không ai cả
Anh Công ơi bạn bị mạng quy khô trả lời
được rồi các bạn sẽ thấy ở đây rõ ràng
là cái bản đồ giấy nó ribery nó thư viện
sẽ cung cấp cho mình thông tin nhưng mà
nó chị cung cấp cho mình thông tin thôi
còn mình sử dụng gì với thông tin đấy
đấy việc của mình đúng không Nó kêu Dạng
Và kéo nó cài cái bản đồ to như thế này
cho mình rất nhiều thông tin từ ai Z
nhưng các bạn với vận dụng nó thì mà làm
để mà đi được hay không Những cái việc
của bạn
Ừ thì tiếp theo là còn về dùng Google
Maps để mẹ cha đó ngon thì nó là Trung
Quốc là theo kiểu là Ừ nó vừa hỗ trợ bạn
tự làm Z nhưng mà và đặc biệt là các bạn
hoàn toàn hệ đổi hướng đi có thứ thì nó
lại đề xuất ra hướng mới được ngoan thậm
chí là giả sử nó hết Nó đường cụt rồi nó
sẽ bảo các bạn quay đầu em ạ đúng hoa
đường có vấn đề gì đó thì nó sẽ cảnh báo
bạn Vân thì cái đấy là Facebook
còn bạn kia nói nó là flash phone hoặc
có lại platform platform là kiểu giản là
kéo nó chính là cái gốc có giống như về
rồi Nó kiểu nó hội chợ các bạn từ A đến
Z
tự làm mọi sự rất là nhanh nho Mỗi tội
thì nó sẽ Rập khuôn nó sẽ chỉ còn những
cây sim có sẵn Như thế gọi những cái log
in có sẵn như thế các bạn sẽ rất khó tùy
chỉnh giống như của ông gọi xe ôm mới
không chỉ ông xe ôm chị đeo đúng đến cái
chỗ đấy thôi ông không thể bà là Anh ơi
em thích đi con đường kia nó mát hơn gì
đó không không quan tâm đúng mực sẽ rất
khó tùy chỉnh đấy Kiểu nó sẽ thường hay
có thể giúp các bạn đi con đường nhanh
nhất nếu mà còn con đường tùy trình ở tù
hưởng các bạn tăng lên thì sẽ khó
Vì sao thể chọn pin mà không lại mắt
thấy còn chơi game cũng đúng vào đợt
Winner hội sợ nhiều cái giống như bây
giờ mày không để nhờ sang linus cũng vì
có thể từ liên quan mình quen dùng Win
cũng như là kiểu
ở trên này cài đặt mọi thứ nó cũng dễ
chơi game đúng không Mà một phần làm
nghĩa cũ cũng dùng Apple nên tôi sẽ ghét
tất cả hành Oppo ở
Ừ cái cốt thuần Đúng rồi Kết thúc Có
phần là tự tự mò kiểu thế Cùng lắm là
lên mạng chào Google thì giống như là
Triệu Vũ Các bạn đi đường rồi hỏi hỏi
hỏi đường bằng mồm vậy
ý thì cái Facebook về sau mình sẽ dạy
các bạn bị sẽ dạy các bạn đã cái lập
trình khóa sau ấy lập trình nâng cao ấy
thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn về foward đang
nói chung là đang phổ biến nhất của pp
nó là
các bạn sẽ thấy cốt mà sẽ nhà hơn rất
nhiều
và nó sẽ tối ưu bạn rất nhiều cái
ê ê
Ừ ok Nói chung á á cái cái này thì đến
cuối buổi mới nói chia sẻ nhé bội mình
chết cuối buổi này mình sẽ chia sẻ với
loa và một trong ba cái này đi để ngoan
ý
đã bắt được buổi họp Thôi thì buổi học
hôm nay thì
chị sẽ học làm cái này
chú chó trông thấy màu mè hơn hẳn đấu ạ
Có họ sẽ thấy em màu mè hơn và hôm nay
mình sẽ dạy các bạn về nhưng mà để trước
khi làm cái này thì đương nhiên là mình
sẽ hiểu qua thế nào CZ nữa đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ làm bài đầu tiên quay lại
bài 1 quay lại chín bài một mình đã làm
rồi nhưng mà heo viết theo kiểu xe thì
các bạn sẽ thấy nó nhanh hơn như thế nào
cho ngon đi
sức khỏe bạn một nhé
thì mình cứ xóa đi này à
Ồ
thông tin CS thì để để làm để làm giao
diện màu mè hơn và tùy chỉnh giao diện
đúng không giống như kiểu trong trường
hợp này các bạn để mà muốn nó thành nền
đen đấy ạ thì các bạn sẽ không còn dùng
bg-color nữa mà sẽ ghi thẳng vào nó gọi
Style như thế này sau đó đi backgroud
xong rồi Black như này là được em mình
sẽ thử này
Xem tivi Star như thế em nghĩ sai như
thế thì nó sẽ tự động sẽ xanh thành màu
đen luôn
ừ ừ
ô kê
Ừ làm đi size kiểu này chính là gọi sẽ
đâu mà
tiếp theo mình muốn cho toàn bộ chữ ở
trong body này sang màu trắng thì hồi
trước là mình dùng thẻ phone xong ngồi
ôm tất cả các chữ đầu ngoan thì thay vì
như thế thì ngay trong body này mình có
thể thêm color là có ai như thế này để
chữ nó luôn hình màu trắng mà sợ mình sẽ
gõ một cái chú gì đó đây
hello
tiếng chuông đúng
ở tại Bình tích áp
anh alo a
ở kiểu Ngày Trở Lại
ở
đó sẽ ra như này
ừ ừ
Ừ
thì nó sẽ nó sẽ làm ngay đúng à mà tiếp
theo ý
a tiếp theo là mình ra sự mình cái ảnh
thì mình bỏ qua nhé Anh thử cái à
Thôi mình thích thì mình xoài nói đi đầy
đủ đầy đủ đúng không ạ sẽ là emg này rồi
chọn một cái ảnh bất kỳ đi
anh gì chẳng được đó
a desktop à
ừ ừ
anh
alo phải đúng đường dẫn á
ừ ừ
anh
suốt mẹ xóa tên file ảnh động mạnh
khi
nó xảy ra như này
hình ảnh này bị to quá Đúng không mấy
ông thấy nó sẽ rất bị to thằng ra mình
có thể chỉnh nó bằng như thế này style
cho nó này sao ngủ ít như này là ví dụ
là chị nói 100 chỗ nào ạ
Lê Văn Toàn
anh hoặc là mình có thể chỉnh cho nó là
22 đi mình chỉ có hai nó thì ổn hơn hay
cho nó Lần này thì mình nếu ghi xe hết
thì mình sẽ ghi thêm chữ Pixel để sửa PS
vào ví dụ là 200
Pixel trả nợ nó sẽ mức tương đồng ai
thôi nó không to quá bởi vì ảnh đấy tôi
tải về ảnh ảnh kiểu đỗ xuân phân dài nó
lên 4k cho nó rất to
à à
Thế là mấy ông kia lại nói cái từ tế nhị
tế nhị không thế không ổn thế xấu đấy à
Ừ nó tiếp theo là
ờ ờ
ở đây một loạt chữ này chắc thế tôi
không hạnh copy có cái gì văn bản để mà
sửa chữa cho nhanh vậy
t2k sự tôi copy một đoạn văn bản này nhá
Cho tôi sẽ vui đỏ
ở nhóm nhớ hồi đầu thiệu khá vất vả đoạn
này nó ngoan
à à
ạ bây giờ giật sự giống như hội đầu của
mình ấy thì mình sẽ phải dùng thẻ Phone
này Đây đúng rồi sau đó đi đóng này
không có thêm color nó chẳng hạn thế
đ.l đúng không là last này có thể thu
này thể bê này đúng à Hay vì mình làm
vất vả như thế thì lần này sẽ là mình sẽ
khi nó là spam như thế này Tại sao lại
Star bởi vì mình không muốn nó xuống
dòng
Anh không muốn nó súng vọng và mình hoàn
toàn thể thì ghi thêm cho nó những cái
class cho nó khái niệm class là kiểu nó
sẽ cho
a cho toàn bộ cái thang này cùng vào một
nhóm đây mình sẽ có class như này ạ Mình
sẽ đặt tên nó lại chữ màu đỏ em ạ
và mình sẽ sửa CS cho cái phần class này
đều ngoại Em có sẽ kiểm nhanh
Ờ Ờ mình sẽ ghi ở trên này tay này
ấn vào đây cách để mình gọi class này
thì mình sẽ dùng dấu chấm như thế này
Sao ngồi tên lát ngọt nhọ như này ở mình
sẽ color-les trắng ạ đó thì biết là tất
cả những cái thằng nào mà có chung cái
class này sẽ cùng sẽ được cùng chữ mua
đỏ đã ngoan là sự là thằng hay đi thằng
hai mình lại cho các bác cho nó
ở đây phán sự đền loại này thì dừng trả
lại 8A
Ý là mình cưới enter nhìn nó rõ đúng
không
à à
em hãy nói chồng nó sẽ kiểu này
đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy ra à
thì
các bạn hoàn toàn thể chính vì cái này
rất là nhanh theo kiểu lại tất cả các
ngày sẽ cung được ghép vào một cái gọi
là class cùng nhóm đó Nhà đấy để để mà
hiệu chỉnh cùng một lúc
a a dùng để chữa bé ngon
à à
Ừ nhưng mà không không run như ra các
bạn khó nhìn nữa
đáy Sơn tiếp theo là kiểu mình sẽ chỉnh
mình có thể chỉnh cái gì nữa mình như
thể chỉnh cho nó chữ này nó in đậm hoặc
là gạch chân nó không ạ thì đây đây mình
sẽ ví dụ các bạn thôi nhé Còn nếu mà các
bạn cần biết đầy đủ tất cả những cái nữa
dụng là kiệm gạch ngang gạch
gì đó vân vân chữ to lên cái thử thử thì
các bạn phải lên cái trang CS này để các
bạn xem mới đầy đủ tất cả của nó thì có
rất nhiều
ở đây Con bây giờ mình sẽ Chị nói qua cơ
3 lít technique origin and like nó sẽ là
gạch chân này đấy thì tất cả đồng đoàn
tất cả bị cái thang này sẽ gạch chân
thực là tên class như này các bạn là tên
để nạn được hôm nào tên là A hay B được
đúng không
Ừ nhưng mà mình mình nghĩ là mình nên
đặt sao cho để mà về sau ông nào Đọc cốt
của ông ông hiểu được cái class này điểm
gì thế nên là việc mà để tên nó chữ màu
đỏ xong rồi ông có thêm gạch chân ở
trong cái chữ màu đỏ là nó vô lý đúng
không cái cách để mà kiểu ông sẽ hiểu là
một cái đó chữ màu đỏ một cái cái chân
thì làm như nào
Ừ thì nó sẽ lại tách ra tôi thường là sẽ
làm tách hẳn ra một cái nó gạch chân thế
này
đây chỉ đang ví dụ nhé Thật là thường
ông đi thẳng vào trong cốc thôi Khi
nhanh hơn việc nó tách ra như thế này
Em hãy thiện cách bây giờ nó các bạn sẽ
thấy nó tận high-class và thằng này nó
sẽ phải có 2 class này không ngoan gạch
chân này gạch chân kinh ngạc bạn thấy nó
vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên để ngoan nhưng bản
chất là nó sẽ gồm nhiều cái class ngay
Bởi vì bởi vì ra sự là cái chữ cô ấy này
chẳng hạn nó chỉ có mỗi màu đỏ thôi chứ
nó không gạch chân thì sao thì hoàn toàn
làm được đồng ăn hay ra sự ngay
a-class là chữ màu đỏ ngay
đó thì nó sẽ được
nhưng mà các bạn sẽ thấy nó có sự khác
biệt một tí đó là
Ừ mình lúc thì mình ghi Style thẳng ở
trong thẻ HTML lúc thì ghi Style nằm
trên cùng như thế này đúng không thì đây
là khái niệm khái niệm
này a
ừ ừ
a
khái niệm tin like HTML ơ
ý chị là nha mày có ghi nghe đi
ở lại internal
elight tất cả sao nó sẽ viết nằm ngay
trong thẻ nó tìm lời như thế này tiếp
theo lại internal tất cả sẽ nằm trong
file của HTML nhưng mà không nằm ở trong
thẻ nó sẽ nằm có thể nằm ở trên nằm ở
dưới nằm ở giữa body cũng được Nhưng mà
thường cách chuẩn của nó sẽ là thường ấy
theo kiểu Google xôi ấy thì nó sẽ nên
nên là nằm trên cùng như thế này để nó
quy ước là cái tài liệu HTML này nên in
ra trông như thế nào đều ngoan
ở đây thì nó sẽ nó sẽ khái niệm kiểu như
thế này
về đến nhà như mình đã nói ra cách này
cách đặt tên lại Thực ra nó không ăn phù
hợp lắm đúng không gì như thế này cho dễ
từng Minh thôi chứ ra phía sau không đội
nón xanh thêm màu xanh nữa nạn thì tự
nhiên phải sửa tên toàn bộ class được là
nó không nên
Ừ đúng rồi Các bạn thấy Tại sao tự nhiên
mình thêm thẻ span ở đây về phía mình
muốn quy ước cho cái chữ này nó thành nó
có cái class thì mình nên phải dùng một
cái thẻ nó đó đúng oan và thẻ liệu Các
bạn nhớ hồi trước là mình thường hay nói
về thẻ văn bản là thiệp p thì nó sẽ bị
nhảy xuống dòng mất Thế mình thường ai
dùng thẻ span span gần như nó sẽ chẳng
làm ảnh hưởng đến cái văn bản Đấy bởi vì
nó không không làm thay đổi cậu xuống
dòng này phải làm độ màu hay các tư duy
cả
Ừ đúng rồi bạn diện nó đúng rồi đấy ạ
Anh ấy tiếp theo là
ạ Bây giờ còn có bạn cũng nói là giả sử
là em Bây giờ em có
11 cái kiểu dạng một cái đoạn định dạng
xét này nhưng mà áp dụng cho nhiều file
cùng 1 lốp thì em làm như nào em lại
phải copy toàn bộ CF này sang từng file
HM màu đỏ không cần nó ngọt thì cái này
sẽ khái niệm nữa là khái niệm external
eternal
tức à các bạn sẽ nhúng khoa CS này xanh
thẳm wi-fi gọi pha CS khác không ạ ạ
thì mình sẽ đặt tên nó là để mô sấm sét
điện
thì mình chỉ cần copy cái đoạn này Thơ
em không cần phải thêm cái xe thêm size
kia đâu nhé Đấy Và ở đây mình sẽ
mình mình cứ tạm để lại cái này bạn sẽ
cái này chấm hôm sau cả thì mình sẽ thật
mình sẽ dùng cái này luôn mình sẽ gọi
Linh ở đây à sẽ tự tắt ra nó sẽ hiển thị
đầy đủ đây này mà mình sẽ nhảy đến cái
file mà file để mua Sấm Sét nhúng nó bảo
đâu ạ sẽ dùng nó vào
các bạn phải là thực ra nó vẫn sẽ giữ
nguyên đóng ngoặc nó không thay đổi gì
cả một vì mình hay vì mình đi thẳng vào
trong internal Thì bây giờ mình sẽ là
nhúng nó như này thế Các bạn thấy Là
cách này nó sẽ nhanh hơn rất nhiều hồn
hồi đầu mình làm bằng in mình dùng nhiều
thẻ có HTML hoặc cả mình sẽ dùng in life
ngoa Mình mà dùng elight ở đây thì các
bạn sẽ thể rất tối tốn rất nhiều kiểu
mình phải mất công copy rất nhiều đúng
không
Em tải ứng dụng tách đi call regina and
live show thậm chí Ở mình còn phải thêm
cả phone web để mà cho chữ cho chữ kiểu
in đậm đè nặng tại như này thay vì như
này thì bây giờ mình sẽ nó mình sẽ viết
theo dạng class Giả sử đây là thêm một
cái nữa đi hãy in đậm nhận ạ
anh ở đây là full web này đã môn này
Anh ấy thì bên này sẽ chỉ chữ màu đỏ
gạch chân in đậm
cái như này thế xong đúng không
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ giải thích cho các
bạn Các bạn đang hỏi ở đây đó là nếu mà
lúc thì em dùng elight lúc thì dùng
internal không có gốc thì dùng external
như thế này mà em cơ hợp cả 3 thứ không
có lúc thì nó có bị sao không hay nó bị
nói ưu tiên cái nào hay nó trộn màu với
vân ở ngoài thì thứ nhất là các bạn đang
thấy là ngay ngay tại thời điểm hiện tại
là mình đang dùng
chữ cái I like cho cái body những thằng
này nó lại dùng cái Methanol đúng không
Nhưng trong trường hợp này thì đương
nhiên là các bạn thấy là rõ ràng actonel
nói thắng bởi vì nó lại gần với cái fan
hơn thằng Ba đi ông ạ nên nó chữ vẫn sẽ
màu đỏ trong màu trắng
nhưng mà nếu mà trong trường hợp mà mình
sẽ ghi thẳng tay ở đây nữa là ví dụ là
Calo là già màu xanh để nhận thế bạn sẽ
thấy nó đổi sang màu xanh đó Ngoan Nó sẽ
không ưu tiên theo thằng external như
thế này Hãy giả sử là bây giờ mình sẽ
vứt thẳng Nitơ ở trong này và đổi sang
thành mộ vang em ạ
Lê Thúy sao theo các bạn thì chữ Bây giờ
nó sẽ hàng
ô chữ hàng một đò trắng
xanh vàng hãy trộn màu à
thì các bạn vừa nghe mình nói dẻo
Ừ bác tự nhiên Bạn này mình nên viết
tiếng Anh đó không ạ
thì
các bạn ý kĩ nhá đây tôi tôi để in life
Green ông ạ external của tôi đó là
màu đỏ nhưng mà ở đây thì cả tội cho mùa
vàng sau ngồi gần I like gần hơn thì nó
màu trắng Rốt cuộc nó sẽ màu gì
Ê mấy ông kia trả lời có vẻ đều đang
đúng hết rồi trong mấy ông hiểu đó ngoan
đúng rồi nó sẽ vẫn là màu xanh thôi thì
các bạn sẽ thấy rõ ràng là nó là eli nó
sẽ quan trọng nhất trực tiếp theo thì
mình xóa thử cái này đi thì nó sẽ đổi
sang
bí đỏ
Ừ đúng rồi nó vẫn sẽ đổi sang một lọ Tại
sao bởi vì rõ ràng Ngày khai báo trước
thằng này thằng này nó sẽ ghi đè lên
đúng không
Ừ
để nó đằng sau nhỉ
Em bảo nó sẽ như thế này thằng này nó sẽ
luôn đi đè lên
cho hai thằng ông sẽ có thể đi đề với
nhau
nhưng không phải chị Mỗi thế mặt hàng
thực ra thằng internal này có sẽ luôn
được
nó sẽ mức độ ưu tiên của nó sẽ luôn cao
hơn đây các bạn sẽ luôn nó theo đúng thứ
tự là luôn
phải Zalo nó sẽ luôn theo đối tượng này
I like luôn là được ưu tiên là internal
của internal nhưng mà các bạn thấy thực
ra đôi khi Tân hồ sẽ được viết đè lên
nếu mà actonel đã bằng sau với cái này
nhờ đây Viết đè lên thẳm cái class class
là cùng tên Nóng ghi đè lên thường nó
không như thế đâu ạ
à à
anh nói chung đại cái đi bé nói qua về
cách viết cfs như thế nào các bạn sẽ
thấy ở CS có rất nhiều thuộc tính tùy
thuộc tính cơ lệ thuốc chữa đổi cho cả
background ngoan đổi capella bàn thờ ra
có thể background cả cái ảnh cũng được
sự đây mình có thể đổi nó phát ra inmei
đi vào đây sẽ là Urani
hình ảnh như này có thật sự đây chứ cái
ảnh này đi Chẳng hạn sẽ copy nhá là sự
đời chúng cái ảnh này lại thì xóa anh
mới đi này à
Ừ đúng rồi Hay là mình có cái giàu nháy
làm sai nhỉ Vậy mình đi ị
mà hãng mù chữ nha Có gì đó sai sai
à à
ở đó
em heo này trang web để mùa sinh động ý
em đứng giờ các bạn thấy à Cái bác rau
này thì giống như mình vừa rồi mình mất
công dung ra các thứ thứ thì bác Laos in
Mass này thường có thêm những cái thuộc
tính nữa giống như là mình có thể chỉnh
background-size cho nó
Khi say sẽ là có vơ tức à ảnh bìa thế nó
sẽ nó sẽ kiểu cố khớp vào Và thậm chí là
các bạn thì chỉ nó cắn nó giữa để cho nó
đẹp hơn thì sẽ bác capo season những nạn
có xin
là Center Center lần 1 thì như tụi mình
nhớ không làm là sẽ ăn
à à
ở trên dưới trước rồi mình trái phải
hiểu phải như mình thường anh dùng cả
hai như này nó là cả trên dưới có cả
trái phải nó sẽ giữa các bạn thấy ảnh đã
bị lặp lại nó bị đắp bịch nó bị lặp lại
cậu để cho khớp với cây không Hình này
thì các bạn hoàn toàn thể
background-repeat no-repeat
sau đó đi repeat này không gặp lại nữa
em lại nói chung đại khái như thế này
chắc là do tôi trúng hai phát Center nhà
nó kêu đi hơi xấu
xe tải
anh tạm thời Thế Đó Ngoại ạ
à à
Ừ đấy thì
mày Ông vừa được xem để mua qua Thế bác
rau tốt thứ thứ đúng không nó còn thêm
những cái gì nữa mình có thể thêm cho nó
những cái kiểu model như Viền Viền do
mua cái bất kỳ
như Nói chung là thôi Tóm lại cô ta bài
tập hôm nay không phải để làm cái này
mày tao hôm nay mình đều làm cái này cơ
xem lại nhé ngấm ngầm mạnh
30 bài này tí tôi ra về nhà cho ông ấy
không phải làm
Ừ tại hôm nay mình sẽ làm cái này
Ừ đúng rồi nóc nhà tôi ngồi ngay cạnh
kiểu anh đang đi mua cái gì đấy heo đi
Anh ở thì tôi bảo ông tập trung ở những
cái thứ tốt đẹp ở đây tôi bảo mày không
Sao lại tập trung những cái khác đâu ạ
Ừ cái thì
Ờ Ờ bây giờ mấy hôm là lại tập trung lại
và bài nào đấy thì mấy ông thấy cái bố
cục của cái chai này Hôm nay tôi sẽ giới
thiệu không phải có công không phải dùng
Thể Thay bồ để làm cái trang web mày nữa
mà mấy ông sẽ phải chuẩn giống như các
bạn đang Hãy bảo nó không phải chia nó
đi nhiều ít cái đít là cái gì vậy Tôi sẽ
thử vãi luôn hơi xấu nhưng tôi có thể vẽ
được đấy đi đầu tiên thì chia bố cục đi
Này các bạn sẽ phải luôn luôn hình dung
nó sao xanh in hình chữ nhật đầu tiên ở
mình sẽ luôn có một người đi ôm tất cả
cùng tất cả cái này đúng không ạ
cho nó chắc là tôi mở cái này một bên đi
cho dễ sửa
Anh tên cái đít
ở đây
số đầu tiên này cậu công sẽ phải có một
clip ôm tất cả cả cái
tất cả các trang web này thường mặc định
là như thế đều ngoan sửa tiết heo là
không lại chưa bố cục nhỏ hơn một tí
thôi đó tôi thường anh chia nó sẽ là
tôi thường ai chia nó là cậu một cái đít
trên và một cảnh Deep xưa ấy đã như thế
này
ở đường à Một cái đít trên rồi đít dưới
tiếp theo nữa thì tôi đã từng nói đó là
kiểu thường ai từ trên xuống dưới và từ
trái sang phải không ạ Tức là cái đít
trên này không phải chia nó thành hai
cái đít nữa một cái đi vợ bên trái này
một cái đít nữa một cái đít ở bên phải
này
có đi Vinh Sài không ạ một cái bí bên
phải như này nó nhà nó thậm chí mấy ông
thích chia nữa thì cũng được nó sẽ thể
chia thêm một cái đít nữa ở trên ở góc
như thế này này nó sẽ trôi lên trên và
một cái đít dừa nó sẽ trôi như thế này
không ai Tôi chưa Dậy không thì posen
đâu đấy Mày không chưa làm được cái vụ
gỗ để nó góp góp như này đâu
tôi chỉ dạy Ông mấy ông mà cái bài tương
đối thôi Ê làm mấy ông sẽ về dùng mạ hệ
B rồi mày không kéo nó đầy nó xuống cuối
như thế này đi
kế tiếp là miếng cư
em làm dần dần để cái đít ở dưới này thì
tao nó là ba cái đít một cái đít bên
trái này một cái đít ở giữa hoa Nó là
một cái đi vào bên phải kiu cả nhà
ở đây Nói chung là rất nhiều đít ông sẽ
nhận ra một cái trang web thông thường
hay gặp trục cái Deep Sea
Ừ đúng hôm nay nó dậy gặp vui xuân nữa
lại quá nhiều
ừ ừ
Ừ em cứ từ từ đã bây giờ mấy buổi một
màn gọi có nhiều bạn nó sẽ cảm thấy quá
tải
à à
Ừ đấy thì nói chung là để làm bài này
thì sẽ phải chia là đấy tương đối ngon
đấy Cái đít không ạ
đi làm thôi
à à
đầu tiên mình sẽ có khái niệm đầu tiên
cái đít đầu tiên lại nó ngoác
à à
Ê bà thường ấy thì mình sẽ thường hay
làm xét theo kiểu lại internal sẽ có một
vài lốp là mình sẽ dùng in like để gọi
chị cho nó nhanh và cũng như là mình để
ghi đè lên cái in tự internal nữa trong
một vài trường hợp giống như mình nói là
cái file external là khi các bạn một
tách hẳn cái CS ra khỏi hát alo cho nó
rõ ràng thì cũng được Nhưng mà hồi đầu
mình dậy ra cốt các bạn chưa dai thế thì
các bạn tách ra thực ra có nhược điểm là
cái ếch cano này mình sẽ phải là qua lấy
luôn các bạn nếu mà về nhà làm à các bạn
không Không hiểu tại sao các bạn thay
đổi xe rồi nó không nhận đó là
khi đôi khi cái trình duyệt các bạn nó
sẽ vẫn nhận cái xe cốp xe S cũ nó không
các bạn tải lại trang các bạn thay đổi
CS mở mới rồi các bạn Tại sao nó vẫn
nhận lại xe cũ tới khi các bạn phải tắt
máy đi mở lại thì mới cậu hoặc Mở trình
duyệt khác thì nó máy kiểu mà mới nhận
CS mới cô đấy Mình không biết mình chẳng
hiểu tại sao nữa như thế mình cứ tưởng
máy liệu nhưng thực ra không bởi lý do
trình duyệt đôi khi nó hỗ trợ nó sẽ cạo
lưu cách lại cái file xe đấy thì thường
là mình phải tải thêm cái tiện ích này
thì ý crea cách này họ nó sẽ kiểu hỗ trợ
các bạn để mà xóa cách cài Cài file CF
cũ bởi vì đấy thế nên là mình mới nói là
Cái vụ mà các bạn đầy hẳn sang file mới
Tannoy ấy thì
Ông
Đồ ngồi control F5 hoặc axít F5 cũng
được nếu mà mình thì thường em mình tại
tiện ích này rồi mình dùng phím tắt Cũng
Anh không sao cả à
à à
Ừ
đấy Nói chung là đái thế nên mình khuyên
các bạn Thời gian đầu có làm I like hoặc
in external thì các bạn đỡ phải Cả thêm
tiện ích cũng nhờ tránh việc các bạn
quên mất nó đang cách để ngon
U23 đầu tiên mình sẽ đặt tên nó nó lại
đi tổng thường mình đặt tên kiểu nha nó
hơi thô một tí tại spa in Nó là
cái này thì thường nói ai đi
Ừ
Chip Để để mình giải thích thêm về cái
vụ Glass với ai đi nhá vừa rồi mình thấy
là nhiều thằng cùng dùng chung cái cái
thuộc tính ví dụ màu màu lấy Hỏi kiểu
đấy thì mình sẽ dùng class này làm chị
nhiều thằng Công dùng còn nếu mà các bạn
muốn chỉ một hàng có cái đấy thôi và xử
giống như cái đít tổng này mình muốn cho
nó là
How to bằng cả màn hình xăm môi có các
thứ tư thì thường là mình sẽ khái niệm
mà ai đi nghĩa là duy nhất chỉ một mình
hay được thôi và cách để gọi ai đi mình
sẽ dùng thăm như thế này thì gọi nó
à à
xe tải chuyển nhảy ra sự mình sẽ có vít
là một trăm phần trăm này sau đó thì à
22 thì không thể 100 được hai các bạn
bắt buộc phải nhập Thường ngay ví dụ là
sự bệnh chăm bằng 800pf chẳng hạn và
thừa mình sẽ cho nó 1 cái
background-color làm một màu gì đó để
sao để mà về mặt tí mà các bạn ngồi hết
tất cả các đít vào trong cái đít ở ngoài
này mà các bạn thấy vẫn còn thừa nó một
tí màu hồng Chứng tỏ là cả bạn không
giỏi toán vô cơ
Em hãy trở hết à
Ừ đấy thịt
a tiếp theo là mình sẽ chưa đít trên màn
ít dừa ấy không ạ bị sẽ có một cái thằng
bit còn trong này
nó sẽ là ID đã
đi trên à
Rồi à
ừ ừ
ở
tại thi trên cái cái bài toán ở đây là
cái thằng thằng con đấy nó vẫn sẽ một
trăm phần trăm của thằng cha Đồng hoặc
không phải một trăm phần trăm của cả
trang web mà 100 100 thằng cha và thằng
hai này cũng theo tỷ lệ phần trăm đáng
ra sự mình một ít trên ba mươi phần trăm
thằng cha thôi sẽ qua một phần trăm lại
cả nhà cho nó màu đỏ đi
a
xít gì đấy này không
Em
định sẽ 79 trăm
mấy ông mấy ông nói cho mấy ông bà để
cảm giảm nhựa 69 nhà cản nó bị lệch ra
bị thừa một tí mổ hồng như này thì mấy
ông sẽ thấy em không giỏi Toán thì thôi
các bạn Mình sẽ chọn là màu xanh đi
Khi mà không bị thừa ra một tí gì thì
các bạn sẽ thấy mình có vẻ Đang làm đúng
ý
xe tải nối tiếp theo clip trên này mình
lại chưa nhỏ giao tiếp
Vì sẽ chia nó trái phải là ngon khi
hồi trước tôi đặt tên kiểu nhé nó hơi bị
khó chịu một tí này Tôi đặt nó là mình
đã đặt cho nó một cái đi tiếp rồi mình
phải đi trên trái rồi đi trên phải tôi
thậm chí là nếu mà thực sự Cái thằng
điên này phải đít tôi tôi lại chia nhỏ
thì đi ra nữa Đợi tí để tôi chọn edit
cái này thì ông sẽ hiểu
cho tôi tôi lại chưa nhỏ Xảy ra nữa thì
nó sẽ lại đặt tên nó lại kiểu đít trên
Chết kiểu tên nó nghe nó cứ kiểu bị đấm
vào nhau đấy cái kiểu như này Thế Thành
ra ở Tôi không thích kiểu như thế
Ừ thì mình sẽ thử ta mình có một cách đó
là mình thay vì mình mất công làm kiểu
là tên cậu như thế nhiều
Ừ thì mình sẽ vì mình có thể đặt nó theo
kiểu như này
Ừ
tôi thể đặt tên nó cực và tôi gọi nó cái
class và cái này sẽ gọi trái
a-class thì ông sẽ nghĩ ra mà thằng khác
nó về sau nó có thể chung cái lát này
nhưng không tôi sẽ chịu làm như thế này
ở với thằng đi trên nhé đi trên này
mà gọi đến thẳng Trái này thì bị sẽ làm
nha Cái này bạn chất là thằng trên thằng
cha vợ thằng con và thằng con nó sẽ có
class như thế này sẽ được thấy
các bạn này bắt đầu đang lão những cái
này chả liên quan đến toán những vẫn đau
não đúng không ạ
Em hãy sau đó đi trên trái như mình sẽ
có cái ảnh đúng không đầu tiên mình có
cho hết cho nó đã 50 phần trăm này
hay cho nó một trăm phần trăm này và bác
Lam nói trước đi đã sự ủng hộ vàng đi cô
gái kiểu Nha
và mình sẽ cho một cái ảnh vào trong máu
vậy Sao mấy ông cứ bảo ở Tôi làm nhiều
cái bát rau màu mè thế màu còn xấu đúng
không ạ Nhưng cái này để mà các bạn hình
dung rõ bố cục sau đó về sau các bạn hãy
xóa hết bát rau đi bởi vì nếu các bạn để
hết và da màu trắng của bạn chẳng nhớ là
cái đít nào là nằm ở đâu đúng không ạ
à à
ừ ừ
thì mình sẽ cho cái ảnh ở đúng
Anh hạnh nằm ở bến
Anh ở Mình cũng ở nhà máy này nhé
Ừ anh ra sự tích ảnh đây đúng không ạ
em copy đường dẫn đã
ạ
sau đó thì cái ảnh ở
thì
nó sẽ ra như thế này chưa Cái ảnh này
thì như mình đã nói thì ra đúng không
các bạn phải buổi sau nữa thì các bạn
mới làm nó đẹp được như thế này nó kiểu
cái ảnh nào có thể nhảy một tí xuống
dưới cái ảnh này chèn là như thế này cái
cái này là theo kiểu nó chẳng theo quy
tắc gì cả để làm được cái chẳng theo quy
tắc gì Kiểu nhìn này thì cho là bộ sau
các bạn học vô season và đặt nó ở vị trí
bất kỳ có thể làm được có bây giờ thì
mình làm cái còn đơn giản thì mình Đành
phải chấp nhận và cái ảnh này nó không
trồi ra được như này để qua giống như
cái ảnh mấy cái ảnh sửa cái này Tí mình
mạnh sẽ thấy nó không phải trồi ra được
ừ ừ
em buổi sau nhé Vậy buổi này mình nghĩ
dại thế này hơi có tải các bạn thôi
anh đi trên này thì ra hơi hơi dài quá
nha cho 20 nhé
và cái 20 thì cái này phải lên 80 đúng
không
anh không lại không giỏi toán
đó sau đó thì cái ảnh này mình có thể
chỉnh sai nó thường là các bạn có thể
chỉnh các bạn sẽ thấy lười hơn quy trình
rõ làm bánh hát em lâu rồi nhanh nhanh
hơn kiểu nhà sẵn ạ Nhưng mà thực tế là
chỉ nên quen dần dịch bằng sẽ nó còn
theo phần trăm nữa
Ồ
không tôi sẽ không chạy qua ông về Lead
hay các từ đâu
Ừ thôi Chị dạy mấy ông cái cơ bản thôi
mà
anh nói nhắc về Martin đã Bắc Ninh được
bắt định với mắc riêng mình thì chắc ạ
buổi sau buổi sóng nữa cạnh như thế em
cứ từ từ đã ạ
anh kêu nói chung là mình sai đây 100 A2
= 100 đi
đó chồng cũng sẽ tương đồng như này có
phải chùi ra vội bởi vì nó hiểu nó không
thể trôi
đầu ngoan
tiếp theo là sẽ sang thẳng đến phải đúng
không
nó không vô sinh ở cả một bài thôi
Mở mic in Building thì nó sẽ về lấy dao
thì chắc phải bụi sau khi sau nữa
ờ ờ
ở đó sau đó mình sẽ lại thêm hai cái đít
rồi Bên này nữa một cái đít phải trên
một cái đít phải người ấy đúng không Đây
chị sẽ tạo thêm cái đít class là phải
nữa à
xe máy xe đạp phải à
thì mình sẽ cho nó ra
xe màu đen in Black II
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là cái cái đít của
mình ấy May mà mình có thêm cái ảnh này
do sự không có ảnh của bạn sẽ chẳng biết
được cái Đi cái màu đen ở chỗ đi đâu
đúng không ạ Các bạn sẽ tự xóa mày thấy
ví dụ là xóa nền từng cái một đi này
đó thì các bạn mới thấy cái màu đen nó
chui xuống dưới này rõ ràng ở đây mình
đang làm là
50 phần trăm phải 50 phần trăm thì làm
hết hai nó phải trên này đúng không đúng
không Bởi vì theo quy tắc của thằng biết
chị là cứ kết thúc bit thì nó sẽ nó sẽ
đẩy cái thằng khác xuống xuống dòng Dùng
B rồi Thế bây giờ làm thế nào thì không
để đổi thẻ span đâu nhé Mà mình sẽ phải
làm cho nó
ở truồng là mình sẽ làm theo cách đó là
mình sẽ cho nó trôi trôi về bên trái
thường là thế
có bảo là mất hàng cho bé trái và thằng
chơi về phải được nó cũng được em trưởng
nhập Mai thường mình sẽ thường làm trôi
và một bên thôi tưởng ai chơi bên trái
nó Tức là sau sẽ flashless này
em
trôi dòng
ở đó bạn sẽ thấy à Mất sử cái thằng bên
phải của mình bởi vì sao Bởi vì ra sự
cẩn thận hay đi các bạn sẽ thấy này nó
sẽ được nó sẽ Cậu Hai thằng nằm đè lên
nhau đúng không ạ nhưng AB trong trường
hợp cả hai thằng cùng flash mép sẽ trôi
về nằm ngay cạnh nhau ở ngoài đấy Đấy là
tác dụng của việc là lúc đầu các bạn
phải cho nó cái be drowned Còn không thì
các bạn không hình dung được rồi cái đít
các bạn đang chơi thì phía nào đâu đúng
không ạ
à à
Ừ đấy thì bây giờ khi mà có đít làm cái
này rồi mình bắt đầu tạo cái đít phải
trên là cái phải xưa ấy
ờ ờ chăm sóc tay tách này nó sẽ control
rồi đấy có bạn nói con chuồn cá chéo
an toàn những cái ông giỏi giỏi ở đây
mấy ông trí ngồi xem của tôi để mà mày
khỏi bong mẹ thế tôi hỗ trợ phần nào các
bạn chắc Ok Cảm ơn các bạn Các bạn muốn
rảnh
Tại mình sẽ tạo làm cái đít phải trên
này không ạ Rồi trong may trong này các
bạn biết rồi nó bản chất đã cái kiểu cái
này sẽ acuff sân và một cái nút thường
này phải nằm trong người for đúng không
ạ Mình sẽ cho nó như iPhone
mấy ông ấy có khi đang đợi tao nói gì đó
sai bắt mẹ thôi đấy
hội cây cảnh đắt tiền em ạ
Ai số có cái nút một tuần
đã gấu em ạ ngon anh gâu gâu kiện ngay
à à
công tác nút này nó sẽ không thể như cái
này vì cái này ra diện cũ lắm thôi
select option nóng thế cho bạn sẽ khác
kệ thôi và cái mình trôi sao mình phải
ngay đúng không ạ thì mấy ông ôm flash
Drive cũng được hoặc cả thường mà mình
sẽ dùng la ở đây mình sẽ là
anh đi phải trên đó ngoại
A tại mình sẽ đẩy lấy tiếp vào đấy sẽ là
trên này
quýt nó bằng một trăm phần trăm đi hay
của nó sẽ 50 phần trăm đi trả nợ thế
background là sẽ là à
em trả lại một ngày nhé
cả hai sẽ màu gì đây mẫu Oppo à
dự báo kiểu Nga
cô gái flash không cần flash nữa
mà mình sẽ là techlife ra sự mình trôi
bên phải tất cả reside thằng nó sẽ như
này
à Còn Blue nữa mà Ok mình sẽ cho cái
Blue rồi đấy thấy là sẽ trôi về đây này
không
xe tải tiếp theo là mình sẽ có thêm một
cái đít ở dưới thôi ông ạ lít rưỡi thì
ra mấy cái này ở dưới thì nó là cái ảnh
đấy chứ không phải là Cảnh
cả mấy cái này là ảnh đấy
thời trang sao
à mình mình có những cái ảnh sẵn ở đây
rồi đấy
xe tải
A và đương nhiên các bạn muốn bấm cái
này để nhảy đến một cái đường Linh Là nó
thì các bạn thẻ ôm lấy ảnh thôi
ạ trà sữa bây giờ mình cấu tạo mới đóng
lại đúng không ạ
anh em có thể này
nó sau đó thì inmate này Vì sao lỗi copy
của đoạn này
à à
cho em cái ảnh này sẽ được
em nói chuyện ngay thẻ này sẽ cắm cái Hz
thế này sẽ đề mà chị và sẽ có thể bấm
được nó Các bạn muốn đẩy muốn cho nó
xuống xuống dưới này đúng à mà trôi sang
bên phải Chánh ạ
không giống nhau
Vì sao không cần cho sang bên phải không
ạ thì à
khi cây xôi sang bên phải
em gái đây
Chị nghĩ sẽ làm gì sao
ở dưới này à
e-blue đóng ngoặc tôi sang phải rồi đúng
không thì giả sử ở đây mình sẽ có nhiều
ảnh nhá bay đi
anh cái ảnh này nó to quá nó đẩy xuống
dòng đấy chúng ta cái như thế hay ảnh
đây tại các bạn thấy đúng không ạ
Ô thế mình có 8 hại cho nha à xe tải thì
mình à Muốn cho cái này chú ơi xuống
dưới thì mình sẽ là vertical Lines đây
và mình sẽ là bắt tâm gì vậy
ừ ừ
Ừ
đúng nhỉ tách bắt Tâm à à
Ông Táo Online tekmatic ô ô
Ừ mình không ngờ cái lạ lắm đâu mà người
thường là chẳng ai dùng cách này để phát
hành cho nó trôi xuống dưới cả
để mình xem xem đã thì cổ
em không nhớ sao rồi thôi ông ạ
à à
khi tách à
Em nói sao
ạ bây giờ
cũng được không đúng
ở cái ở đoạn này tôi chơi bây giờ nhé
chợ hoa mấy ông chơi cách nhà kiểu cho
hai cái này cao lên hai cái thấp thì rõ
ràng cái thằng này nó sẽ ở dưới thôi
cũng được mà sống mà đúng không
à Còn bây giờ thì ra ông dung ra luôn
tao cái ảnh nhảy nhảy đi đấy đúng không
ạ
Ừ rồi cho hai ngày cao nhé 90 90 phần
trăm tôi bị thằng kia chạy nhảy như này
lời
à à
hệ thống kê nói display-flex sơ mi kẻ
chuyên nghiệp này chúng ta có chưa động
đến ở đây vội chúng ta đã làm kiểu
mới cái chích các thứ tư đã
em gọi anh kéo nha theo đúng cho ff nó
dưới rồi không ạ ạ
em yên tâm tí xóa hết background đi
chẳng anh nhận ra được cái vụ đấy đâu
số đo tiếp theo cái này Thế các bạn sẽ
thấy cái đít này bạn chất nó cái đít ở
dưới đúng không Nhưng mà mình sẽ không
dậy các bạn đầy đủ thứ cả này mình chỉ
nói qua nốt về cái vụ Kiểu cái đít ở
dưới này kết hợp với cái ba đây nó sẽ
như nào mình sẽ dạy các bạn phải từ 3
đơn là chủ yếu
đít này mình sẽ có class này là
trái giữa và phải ở nặng ạ
Ô Kìa mình sẽ có
thường là mình sẽ ưu tiên đẩy cái thằng
đít dưới này xuống nằm cùng với con của
nó dưới này thì nó trông tướng Minh hôn
kiểu nhà sẽ đít trên này không thấy sẽ
là
à à
ở đít dưới này kiểu như là nhìn cho nó
dõi
Em hãy và bây giờ mình sẽ ra nữa là trái
thì sao đúng không trái giờ sửa mình sẽ
là Ông
Ba Mươi phần trăm thôi hay một trăm phần
trăm màu
e-movie các mẫu vẫn lách nha à
Ừ địt người trái
Ừ đúng rồi
Ừ đúng rồi nào để xem Tại sao sai
- background green
Ơ cái thằng ri mình lấy thôi có mẹ bay
mất đâu rồi đúng không ạ
Ừ anh xóa thử thông tin sao mà
mất gene rồi
Ê thằng ri này của mình làm mất rồi
Ê
tao thấy sẽ tự Sai ạ
Ê con chó sẽ sai đây Tít dưới ấy
khi đôi khi các bạn thực sự không biết
sao sai thì các bạn sẽ nhấn inspect cả
nhà rồi Các bạn chọn là
hình ảnh cho bạn xem
cho biết tổng nha đúng đi trên oddee
trên của mình đang bị vỡ mình cho cốt
bạn đấy là bị sai mình đóng tít tít trên
lại ôm cái đít dưới rồi đúng không ạ
thành ra nó sai đi trên này
cô gái nói xe ôm sợ mất cái đít giấy rồi
à quên chưa đóng đít tổng luôn tại sao
à À quên cho đang đi trên đúng rồi quên
chưa đang đi trên Thành A Dạo này nó sai
Ok
mẹ đọc đi trên này
cho tiếp sữa đây nè
à à
Ừ anh xe control trên cho nó tát cho
chuẩn
cho tao nha Đây cái đít này đúng không
em
mình hơi loạn bắt đầu loạn đấy 2,5 đây
này thằng này phải làm vào đây này thằng
này quên chưa đóng này tắm này Ok sau đó
đến đít sư giấy rồi đi tập Ok đó gì chưa
xe tải thì
em cây ké Nói chung à Cái này thì lỗi
này là ai cũng có thể về sau sẽ gặp thôi
Quan trọng các bạn xử lý tình huống với
những là thôi ông ạ Các bạn không thể
than trời được
10 tại mình không quen cốt mà sao lại
tách lắm lâu lắm rồi mà cốt là sau khi
tách thưởng cốt bằng mệt cài ID khác thì
nó tự động tác cho mình và Nó hiển thị
cho Minh kiểu rõ ràng là kiểu thằng nào
đám thằng Hảo chưa đóng cái gì Thì đó sẽ
rất chuẩn hơn thằng sau khi tách thì nó
chuyển mức tương đồng như thế này
vợ chồng ơi mấy ông kia đám khuyên nó vé
cốt mà không Tôi vợ lối viết code rồi lí
do nó Tôi không dùng
Ừ Ok nói trước là đoạn này thì giống như
cách mà mình vừa làm để mà các bạn muốn
cái ảnh này thì các bạn à Một là dùng PR
xuống đúng không Hay là công chơi trò
giống như tôi về chơi đó trong cái đít
to thế này sao để cho nó hay nó chiến
những đoạn này thôi cũng cái đít dư ấy
chưa mỗi cái ảnh này thì cái hay cái đít
bé này nó sẽ luôn ở dưới đấy Kiểu gì thế
ạ
Ừ
nhưng mà tôi sẽ không nói thêm cái vụ
đấy mà
à mà nói về cái bao đồng này đúng không
có tiền thì giữa phải đã đúng không dám
giữa cái giữa phải nữa
giữa này và phải là chẳng hạn thì
Ờ để mấy cái thằng này cùng một hàng như
mình đã nói thì mình sẽ dùng flash đúng
không ạ
anh không có nói chuyện là thằng này
flash led thằng này flashlight rồi thằng
này thằng nó rỡ chẳng chẳng biết phải lo
đi đâu nhá sẽ không làm thế mình sẽ trôi
hết và một bên thôi đỡ nhân về sau các
bạn sẽ không dùng hẳn dùng cái thằng
flash ngay đâu mà các bạn phải sống theo
cái thằng khác nữa
nhé mình đang ví dụ thế
Lúc đầu thì các bạn chỉ cần biết khái
niệm mày thôi
ờ ờ
ở giữa ảnh cho nó màu gì nhỉ quyền sự
tất cả màu
ở lại màu đỏ đi bí đỏ màu tím màu hồng
Hường
ở Aqua ạ
thế này đâu nha thằng giữa to hơn nó
ngon giữa thì các bạn làm thoải Toán thì
nó sẽ lấy 30 cộng 30 60 cái này 40 mà
hẹn rất giỏi Toán à
em gái thi nhưng mà Ở đây bây giờ cái
trường hợp này ông thấy ở đây còn cái
viền không ạ cái video này nó sẽ ảnh
hưởng đến cái cái kích cỡ để em thử xem
nhé à
Ừ cái việc này tôi để nó là một tí đi
riêng cái thằng này sẽ có là bò tơ
LED một vết và nó sẽ nói gợi ý cho tôi
vừa lục cái luôn đấy nó lít này tức là
viền nó sẽ liền liền và nó sẽ là màu của
sự ngủ xanh Nhã như này cũng sẽ thấy nó
sẽ đẩy luôn cả cái thằng Aqua ấy xuống
bởi vì sao Bởi vì cái quýt này cái with
này nó là kể chiều chiều dài đúng không
ạ chiều dài của cái đít như kệ board nó
không tính mà cái chiều dài này nó độc
lập nó sẽ cộng vào với nhau thành ra là
kiểu hai con thêm một tí Border thôi đã
khiến đẩy Thằng này không còn một trăm
phần trăm nữa nó sẽ đầy thằng kia xuống
thế nên là mình mình sẽ không không chơi
cho các kiểu nghe được anh
em thường thôi hôm trước tôi chơi à Tôi
phải chơi với cho hơi bự bữa tớ đội cái
29 phần trăm
nhưng con đã là cây xanh bị bỏ bơ thì
người ta không nhận ra đâu ạ
Ừ kệ cái đơn nghĩa là vì sao các bạn học
về report về cái độ kiểu nói chung ở
tương thích và giao diện các thử thứ thì
các bạn sự thế không cần dùng phần trăm
như này nữa thứ II
Ờ Ờ
nói chung các bạn chỉ cho nhiều cách
Nhưng mình chỉ đang hướng dẫn các bạn
với các bạn chỉ cần biết qua như mày
thôi còn đương nhiên về sau câu Ông ôm
sử template nào đó về thì thực ra nó
lạnh hơn
sản phẩm tôi tôi vẫn chỉ dạy các bạn
thôi không phải dậy sâu sâu hơn được tất
cả cơ bản đã nhưng cứ bình tĩnh đã
ừ ừ
Ừ ok Nói chung là đại khái công sẽ thấy
có cái mô đâu nó bao lâu rồi
a 1px solid Brass
ở bên trái Vậy để nó sang bên phải đúng
đấy Cái cái một ít nó bé quá vậy tôi sự
tăng nó lên những Đông sẽ thấy nó có có
phiên đã thì có tính viên em ạ anh em sẽ
làm việc cho cái này đi
à à
Thế Hiển thị tách dài quá thì phải làm
sao á Các bạn sẽ phải tìm hiểu cái chăn
kết rồi cắt tách chọn kết cách ạ
anh có thể dùng CF để xem kết trong lòng
rất là đẹp hồi trước mình có dùng coupon
đây đây thì ra đủ kiến thức của Bộ hôm
nay đấy Mình đưa báo Hậu trả lời câu họ
nhé
đi công chuyện điện thoại về ngồi làm
lại cái bài này nó cả bài đằng sau mà
ăn kết
mở Bách
à à
Em không biết dùng cái này không
à mà Cái này dùng mà da spa
Khi bữa trước bị xem cái chăn kết trong
đèn flash
ô chữ giải quà không
Ừ đợi Thủy điểm thi à
có xe ô lin nhớ like
ba ngày trước cửa nhà sẽ cắt chuối của
ông và thay bằng dấu chấm chấm dứt thực
ra cái này chưa đủ đẹp đâu Tôi nhớ có
cái đẹp cực nó sẽ kiểu hiển thị kiểu mờ
mờ lần sau với Quỳnh xử rồi
ở đại khái Thế ông sẽ biết từ khóa như
thế đúng không ạ
ờ ờ sẽ đau đầu nhất là cái gì hả đau đầu
nhất là CS tôi thể Đau đầu vãi tôi cứ
phải ngồi chính diện rất là mệt lấy do
tôi không theo bên đó diện đi
Ừ cái đại khái như thế còn là
3 bài tập thì tôi sẽ gửi cho mẹ mày Ông
mày ông sẽ phải làm bài làm bài này đúng
không làm từ đầu đến cuối bài này tiếp
theo là cái bài này
chứ không phải làm tại Hai Bà Liên
32 bài này mà Mấy ông không dụng con xin
được ca nó hơi tệ nha Mà thôi mà em cứ
làm đã ăn sâu vào buổi hôm sau mình sẽ
thì sẽ dậy buổi xin nghỉ không sẽ làm
bài nó nhàn hơn
Ừ nếu thấy bài Tôi dậy rồi mà
vé máy bay đi Tôi vất vả lắm
Ừ nếu ông kia có nhắc nỉ cũ sao ấy nhỉ
mình quá
em có thể quên đi
Bắc Bình
Ừ rồi tôi bây giờ chắc À cũng chín rồi
nhanh phết nhỉ Mình sẽ chỉ qua các bạn
với cái lazyload thì cái bài này từ
chính Cái của anh tôi đi Phú Thọ ngồi
đấy thôi Đấy mình còn theo dõi anh này
và thấy cái bài rất hay
Ừ cái cái cái này nhá Thử lên trang thế
giới di động nhé
Anh nói hồi trước 0,3 giây mà
ở thế giới di động sập vậy
e hèm Tôi muốn mạng vậy
anh alo
à à
ở
đây lên đó
từ 1,9 dậy không ạ
ờ ờ baber Các bạn nhìn thấy nhá Đây là
đa 1,9 giây đúng
ở đây mình thử tải lại tra xem nó còn
bao nhiêu đây nhá
thật là lâu hơn
ông thầy Chắc là thay đổi cố rồi không
không không đi mua thằng này nữa để hết
đi mua này
khi con Thảo nha nhớ còn hai tháng Tiki
vậy
Em 12 giây đang định đi mua này chạy
nhanh tự nhiên sẽ chậm hơn
hai tay 1,6 giây này Tại ra 0,8 giây này
Tại sao mẹ lại 0,7 giây
đăng ký ngay tại trang nữa là nó chỉ
quanh quẩn không phải 7 0,8 giây thôi
nhưng thực tế cái bài toán ở đây Tại sao
lúc đầu các bạn vào mất 1,8 giây đúng
không ạ sau đó thì
mô tả lại tra thì nó lại nhanh như thế
chính là cái mà vừa rồi mình là qua các
bạn về cách cách hết
Ừ thứ nhất là mấy thằng này các bạn kéo
xuống này kéo xuống nó mấy thì chị thoát
dần thêm các ảnh các sản phẩm này
Ừ đấy Kéo xuống là mày lót dần thêm nhé
Ngày thứ nhất thứ hai là
ảnh này của nó thực là anh này chỉ đủ để
nhìn thôi cho anh ấy thực ra rất là mầu
anh lại độ phân giải nó không thấy cao
đâu các bạn bấm vào thì nó mới hiển thị
rõ ra ảnh thêm rõ ra
e-center này buổi sau trong mình sẽ giới
thiệu các bạn tất cả thí sinh thân mình
đang dùng là tên là Tích lost-time xem
tốc độ tải của sao Ờ
ý thì cái bài toán ở đây cái cái trang
web đang dùng thì nhớ là nó kết bạn nó
sẽ kết lại những cái gì nó sẽ cách tải
những cái ảnh mà gần như ở sẽ ít thay
đổi giống như cái ảnh bìa này hay các hư
thứ cho ta những cái CS mà ra Switch của
trên trang web này ngồi bạn sẽ được lưu
lại để cái thứ nhất thứ hai cái ảnh này
sẽ được Los theo cậu gọi lazy nát tất cả
khi các bạn kéo xuống đến nó thì nó mới
bắt đầu được tải tại dần dần lên trước
lúc vào trang web thì lại cái ảnh này
chưa cross luôn ảnh hưởng nghe cái nặng
nhất là phải thót tim ở đâu đấy tiếp
theo nữa là ảnh nó ảnh này lại còn nó
chơi là ảnh ảnh này là cái ảnh bé Anh
thăm lồ nên là nó sẽ thức lượng nó không
Bạn đã cao nhưng mà phù hợp để chị ra
kiểu nho nhỏ kiểu nha các bạn ấn vào nó
có gì chị gửi ảnh to đấy Đấy do mà khiến
cho một cái mày Cái trang web này tốc độ
tải của dứa nhanh Các bạn thấy là 0,7
giây là con nhanh ở ngã ba Google
Bật Google nó còn kiểu mất không cũng
0,7 0,8 giây thận chứa Đôi khi em mất
một giây nghĩa là mấy thằng này nó cạnh
tranh Tiểu Như thế cả trang web nó rất
là nhẹ
anh thấy thằng Thế Giới Di Động cũng
thấy đấy Chẳng qua vừa rồi Chắc mạng
mình có vấn đề gì đấy thôi đấy thì thì
anh ngay có giải thích về tất cả mấy cái
kiểu đấy để cái khiến cho một cái trang
web trở nên cậu mang tiếng có rất nhiều
ảnh đúng không cái bài toán ở đây là một
cái trang web chuẩn Rõ ràng cái đấy
trong cái rất nhiều hàng rất nhiều HTML
Đáng lẽ trang web phải lót chậm hơn
nhiều phải trang web nếu mà nó nhanh như
thế bởi vì nó kết hợp việc cf1 rất nhẹ
nói với kết lại cứ thứ lại rồi dùng mạch
thăm này đấy ạ
Ừ đúng rồi bây giờ cái bài toán nhá
người dùng đôi khi có thể click nhầm bảo
là sử người dùng nhắn tìm kiếm em ạ Tìm
kiếm mua sắm và sự ra sự giống trường
hợp của mình này mình ghét shopee vì li
ti kia ạ nhận mình ấn và tìm kiếm một
sản phẩm béo Tự nhiên thằng shopee nó
lại ạ kiểu chạy show quảng cáo của thằng
Google lên trang nhất lên à lên đầu mạnh
thay vì thằng Tiki cho dù đôi khi ông gõ
cả bạn chữ Tiki nhưng mà thằng shopee nó
vẫn còn có từ Tiki ông đấy em ạ thành ra
xong shopee nó vẫn được lên trước thằng
tí gì ạ xong rồi người dùng lỡ bấm nhầm
vào trong ạ người dùng chưa cập kịp phát
ra mà tự nhiên đã thấy rõ các sản phẩm
của mình thích rồi người dùng có thể ở
lại mua luôn chứ không phải người dùng
ẩn thoát ra nữa
Anh thành ra là Kiểu cái bài toán mát
trang nhanh là để cũng ngăn việc người
dùng cậu lỡ Click vào không thoát ra
luôn có người dùng Nhấn vào đợi 34 giây
người dùng thoát được dùng lúc đầu tưởng
mạng mình có vấn đề nóng
à à
có ai nhưng mà ngoài ra lại có những cái
trang kiểu
ờ ờ
ở Sendo này xem sen đỏ
ấy thì cái trang này nó Cậu bị nặng quá
này thấy tốc độ tại trang nữa lâu này
Đấy xong rồi
ở cấp 10 lần và cái việc cái nặng của
thằng Tiki 2 các cầu thủ này
cái loa thì nó không hạn nặng ngôn ngữ
ra giây lát nó công nghệ cái áp dụng
công nghệ
một cái chậu cái thứ toán gì đó kiểu cỡ
Thế bạn dùng Switch để mà làm cũng được
nhiều thằng thường sẽ là mở ra Speed II
Ừ anh vừa rồi mình nói qua việc lắm
3 cách để mà làm trang web của các bạn
đang sống luật có phải chuyên nghiệp hơn
đúng không cách cho thằng ông lớn là
a medium marumi sẽ nói về cái gì nhỉ
anh nghe em
Ừ hình như cũng hết rồi đấy hết cái thứ
mà nói rồi còn mỗi season và Somewhere
ừ ừ
Ừ để hôm nay nói hai buổi xong nói nhé
thông tin video sáng tối mà còn on
Facebook thì tôi sẽ bây giờ nha Vào
Facebook tôi còn non thì tôi sẽ chia sẻ
với ông Mười Cái xanh sân còn không thì
thôi
nó vẫn còn non thật này cho tôi điện
chia sẻ với ông ấy ếch xanh sân vậy
Ê mấy ông cứ hỏng hôm nay xem sửa hết
rồi hôm sau tôi có gì mà xem đúng không
ạ
cho thuê sẽ cho mấy ông xem cái bài tuổi
từng đăng rồi
Ừ thôi nhiều
ex5 gái không Không phải cái này
ca nhạc sến nhạc
Ừ cái này thì tao tôi chia sẻ từ lâu rồi
ở nhà video của để cái đấy Hay như là
tôi mới cho ông xem ạ Để xem chân máy
tao còn không nhiều thứ quay lại hẳn
video đấy mà
quay lại hồi ấy tôi qua nhiều video cãi
về tôi trông sẽ
em ở nhà Tôi sẽ cho mày không xem sử mới
đúng video này của tội hết rồi
để có nhiều video trong ngày đặc sắc
không
đợi tí tôi không biết nên mở mở nhạc có
hết tí cái kênh này nó bị đái mãn quyền
đấy nhưng tôi xin phép toán nhà ở
ê
đê tiện ích đầu tiên là tiện ích speed
test
Xem tin nhắn mà không biết để làm gì cái
kẹo đo tốc độ mạng
à à
a Tiếp theo là cái tiện ích mà bấm Ảo
cái lập tức Lưu lại cái bài đấy lưu lại
cái trang web mà ông nắng xem
vào cái danh sách đã lưu ở trên Facebook
tôi thường anh dùng cái danh sách để hai
khách
a tiếp theo cái tiện ích chủ của Google
kiểu bôi đen nó sẽ tự động dịch
ở nhà thuê vẫn con chim mới
a tiếp theo của diện tích mà kiểu ông
quan hệ chia sẻ tài khoản của ông thường
này tài khoản vip 2 tài khoản gì đó ống
nhựa chia sẻ không chỉ cần copy cái
đường Linh này rồi vứt cho thằng khát
khác vào đường link này đăng nhập vào
tài khoản ông mà nó không hề biết mật
khẩu Tên đăng nhập của ông rất tiện
đương nhiên là cái thằng trang web này
nó thì nó bị sập rồi Vậy thì ăn bản
quyền cho tôi vậy nếu mà có tiện ích của
Triều Tiên bạn thay thế thì định UT mà
Cookie ông có thể dùng để lấy cái cũng
được
nghe những chia sẻ quyền đăng nhập thôi
Ừ nhưng mà tôi rẽ nhá Với có thằng nick
nó vẫn bắt chặt lấy cái vụ quá nhiều tài
khoản cùng truy cập cùng lúc
Ừ cái này do tôi chưa mở cái tiện ích để
chế độ ẩn danh em chưa chưa được
anh không hơn nó giống tóc em Facebook
nổ Quốc khi mà Đây cứ tiện ích mà có thể
lấy chữ từ ảnh phát tiện nhược điểm là
nó mới hỗ trợ tương đối vụ tiếng Việt
thôi tiếng Anh thì chắc là nó chuẩn hơn
bí đại tiện ích mà thay đổi chỗ cái
trình duyệt ông muốn đổi sang sim duyệt
khác phù hợp kiểu để mặc test code của
ông mạnh trên trình duyệt ie 11 à mà
tương tự tiện ích này là để mà động thay
đổi giao diện màn hình các bạn xem cục
Xem kiểu trang web của các bạn được giao
diện Cái gì Cái gì đó nó ạ
à tiện ích Hải Hồi đấy Mình rất thích là
tiện ích tự động Điền toàn bộ thông tin
hồi đấy à thằng Google nó chưa có cái vụ
này nên có thích mẹ rất tiện
khi con tiện ích này nữa là tiện ích cơ
à à tên tên nó nói lên tất cả nó quét
audio Ripper nghĩa là kiểu lệch đấy nó
cậu có từ 3 đến sẽ rất nhiều cái thứ để
mà làm được chứ web
300 mạnh ô tô con nít tiện ích tiện ích
kiểu nó lưu tài khoản giống kiểu
classpad đấy à
để tay tôi cho ông xem cái này nó cho
anh xem một video rồi có cái tiện ích
thôi tất cả thế nó đơn giản hơn sự cố
tôi luôn mặc định chọn cái độ phân giải
màn hình ở kích cỡ màn hình luôn không
mình
Ừ
cái tiện ích này là cái tiện ích mà để
kiểm tra xem mà cái đường link của ông
có có hợp lệ hay không này về sau không
làm trang web thì ông ấy cần bệnh viện
ích kiểm tra với chú Linh
và cả cái này nữa nó tiện ích để mà đánh
giá xem cái trang web của ông nó
được cho mấy điểm về việc là CF ra Swift
như nào xong rồi các thứ nói cho mấy ông
làm được chín web bây giờ là cực hình
phạt cận Cài mấy cái tiện ích để mà hỗ
trợ đúng không Đây là đánh giá này đánh
giá cậu trang thiếu bảo mật này trên máy
thì đúng nhưng thiếu còn bận rồi nhưng
mà cần thêm nhiều cái nữa
xe tải virus ở thẻ ảnh mà thiếu cái đúng
cái mô tả vân này đánh giá hết
Ở
đây còn tiện ích còn tiện ích này còn
chưa tim farwell Hội Nghĩa Bây giờ gỡ
Cũng đỡ rồi Vậy à
đặc biệt đội trưởng tế ngày là tiện nó
giống kiểu blog và kiểu có thể chặn vĩnh
viễn mấy cái HTML và ông khó chịu
Ừ ông thấy ở đây không Nó là chặn theo
cậu dạng là ID của cái đít đấy
mà nó sẽ lưu lại trên cái Thị Bích
Ngân hàng nha Có ông vào trang đấy lần
nữa thì sẽ không bao nhìn thấy cái thằng
làm có cái đi đấy thì thường là Cái đít
Cái đít quảng cáo ra nó cũng nằm trong
cái ID nó đó ông chạm nó là không Bơ
Nhìn cái đít cô gái đi nữa mà còn như
chẳng quảng cáo không ạ tương tự thấy
không thể áp dụng cả trên Facebook nhé
cảm ứng dụng trên rất nhiều web như bạn
muốn web xem phim không
đó bây giờ tải lại sau sẽ không còn nhìn
thấy cái đít gì nữa
sự
nhạy cảm vãi chưởng đây
cái tiện ích này là tiện ích Hồ ấy còn
dùng ngon hình như không còn dùng nữa nó
là Tĩnh hoever zoom chỉ và ảnh lập tức
cả ảnh nó sẽ
phóng to lên bà ấn nút test thì nó sẽ tự
động lưu
khi tôi dùng cái ví dụ nó hơi nhạy cảm
đấy anh em thông cảm
à à
ở chung cuối có giả mà thất vọng đúng
không ạ
a Huy Đấy được ra hồi ấy tôi có quay rất
nhiều video này để tôi chia sẻ cho anh
em sẽ bao gồm cả việc à
từ hôm nay tao còn hướng dẫn
cái bài đăng đầu tiên tôi chia sẻ nó bài
đăng có đấy tôi mò bạn nhỏ cụ mà kiểu
tôi xem mình Tôi muốn học tiếng Anh xem
từ một cái video nhưng video không phụ
đề nên là tôi muốn cậu dùng máy tính tự
động auto sóc sẽ tự động cho tạo Sắt
bằng tiếng
cách tạo sắp ra tự động từ video ấy
ở Huế tôi sẽ chia sẻ là cái này
Ừ nếu mà thứ hai như cái thằng này nó
rung
cái ít cái này Google nên nó bị vỡ vậy ạ
Ừ tôi chưa chạy cái gì vậy Hay Hay đây
con chatbot đầu tiên đôla Hồi này tôi ra
ngoài tôi chia sẻ con support đấy chương
trình đầu tiên công ty xong rồi cậu một
loạt ông cứ ngồi Farm 1 ngày lên là
5.000 người spam không ạ
spa đã xem ảnh nó sẽ tự động gửi ảnh mấy
ông này mấy ông cẩn tiếp tiếp là nó lại
gửi thêm tiếp rồi Thế xong rồi ấn vào
cái phần hộp thư của pac nhìn thấy mấy
ông starman tục ngay trong cảm thế phê
không cảm thấy sản phẩm Ông làm ra cậu
nó được nhiều người đón ý
ừ ừ
cho con cái gì chia sẻ nữa nhỉ
Vì vậy tôi làm nhiều nhiều cái phết
ở đâu sao
à à
ở đây chia sẻ nốt cái cái
video này nhé
ừ ừ
Ừ cái này là tôi tôi chia sẻ cốt nên
nhóm đúng không
ở nhà máy ông thích mày không thể tải về
mấy ông cảm thấy sợ bảo mật thấy gì đó
miếu để tải về
Ừ tôi tạm bỏ qua vụ cài đặt đi
ở thời đại phá như thế này có 2 cái file
đúng
hay sai để chạy cốt này cho mày Ông mở
lên mà chạy này
AE nhập Token Facebook mà
ạ sau đó đi nhập tên thư mục mong muốn
muốn là sự đây tôi đầm ôm một bạn này có
lấy ID ở bạn đấy
ạ sau đó tôi nhập ID của bạn đấy ạ
xe tải sau lập tức ở ra tên bạn đời ở
nút tải thế xong như trò đùa
em hỏi
thì nó sẽ tải hết toàn bộ ảnh kèm toàn
bộ album của lấy luôn kết hợp đồ ngoài
mắt cỡ
Em hãy thậm chí ở cả từ nhóm đúng không
ạ
à à
anh lái xe tải tất cả ảnh từ nhóm này
dịp Tết này
cho tôi bảo tôi chia sẻ rất nhiều tung
lên Facebook mà cái ông không tìm hiểu
gì cả hơi buồn
à à
Ừ
hi vọng dung lượng nó không đủ lớn rồi
mà lại hết ở ngoài đấy không ạ
khi
tôi còn làm và tool tại video rồi tung
tất cả nhiều cá lắm à
xe tải Mèo Hoang học lập trình học xong
khóa này cởi nước là khóa này yêu nhau
không cần khóa sau được làm được tất cả
máy này nó không còn khó đâu ạ
Anh ở thì tôi bảo mày không lên lại đâu
đâu mà sách cơ mà không mời lên tải thôi
Đây Rồi Chia sẻ qua với người hãy sang
sân sau một buổi sau tôi sẽ chia sẻ
những phần mềm đó đang dùng được mắt à
Ừ chắc hiểu nhỉ cho Hôm nay thật ra rất
dài đấy mình tặng gì nhé à
Ừ miễn là cái gì ông xem được thì nó tải
được thằng to Kem bản chất nó là lấy
quyền của ông mà ông có quyền như thế
nào hoặc là ông trộm câu Ken của cái
người nào mà có quyền để xem ngoan ông
nhập Tok em người vào thì sẽ sẽ tự động
tải Với tư cách người đấy nghĩa là người
lấy xem được Tùy mình tải được đúng như
thế mà
ừ ừ
cách tạo như thế nhỉ kê cho các bạn
và hẹn gặp buổi sau em
à à
ừ ừ